the hardest respect to earned is one
zone and this was something that was
really hard for me is that I had a
pretty bad reputation in the very
beginning of my college career in all of
my high school career and it was because
I drank too much I was irresponsible I
slept around a lot and I wasn't
representing the tempers that I wanted
to be and so I felt ashamed of the
behaviors that I did but I didn't change
them and so it was only through a
conversation I had with my father where
I said how do I change my reputation how
do I get these people to stop saying
this stuff and I thought there was some
like PR marketing angle that I could
take that I could control the narrative
and he said why don't you stop being a
piece of [ __ ] but I was like that can't
be it I'll figure out a way when parents
talk to kids they're listening but
they're not listening that really stuck
with me and I started thinking about it
and so I said like well if I wanted to
be somebody who was respectable what
would I do and so then I tried to start
acting in that way to be someone who's
respect my own I would earn and so when
I started doing that nothing changed
externally people still treated me like
I was piece of [ __ ] and they were
probably right but my behavior began to
change and then slowly so did my
reputation but it started with me trying
to respect myself first and then others
began to respect me as a result